[Music]
hey everybody
it's monday yeah yeah
we're doing uh oh we're doing the
amusement park one right
[Music]
i gotta be honest man this when this
came on it was so
kind of to me it kind of it seemed like
such a downer i didn't want to see it it
was a downer because
i was like man it's about it's about
getting old and all these old people and
[ __ ] and i was just like i don't know
about this man
like when you get as old as me you don't
want to think about it you know you're
like i know
about how how old you can get and how
you just become [ __ ] obsolete people
forgetting about you
and they were showing people like in the
bumper cars and the old lady gets out
you know the bumper car you know just
getting accused for
causing an accident she goes how old are
you she goes i'm 65 and i'm looking at
it and i go
that's 65.
it had to been a lie she looked like
she's about 85.
although old people looked much older
back then yeah
it was about 85. yeah back in the 70s
yeah yeah so
like i didn't really know it's really
weird because i didn't know what the
backstory of this was i just thought it
popped up on shutter
and literally all i knew about it was
they said this is a movie that was made
by george romero directed by george
romero back in 1973
and it was thought to be lost uh because
it had never been
shown anywhere uh but i guess they found
it like and the george romero foundation
uh in cahoots was like some other like
restoration they actually restored it
um you know as much as it can be
restored well as much as it could be
restored because
and i think it says at the end that the
only print they found it was like a
really shitty one
so it's like you know you can't you
can't polish a turd well you can but you
know what i mean they showed that on
mythbusters
that you could polish a turn but i'm
just saying that you can't like
something that looked this bad
you know you there's only so much you
can do so it looks decent but it still
looks like really
low budget the thing is the color looks
very faded in it yeah it's real washed
out and it's nice and it's in before
three aspect ratio it's not like in a
film
yeah and it's not real sharp the images
are not real sharp
what i so the back story behind this was
in 1973
um george romero of all people
got commissioned by it was kind of like
the
it was some kind of religious
organization like the lutheran something
rather
and they wanted to make essentially a
psa
about elder abuse right yeah
so i don't know if it was their idea to
make it like a movie or like a story
that was like supposed to convey this
idea
but um or if it was george romero's idea
but it's like george romero was probably
not the best person to give a project
like this too
because even though it does come across
like a psa from the era
it also comes across like a surrealist
nightmare
which they should have expected really
yeah almost kind of like a
black mirror or twilight zone something
like that
like i said i wasn't really trying to
focus in on it too much once i realized
that it was
i just wasn't in the mood for for for to
to
get depressed
[Laughter]
and they're doing it on purpose well
yeah because they wanted they wanted to
get across because there's even like at
the beginning in the end
the main dude that's in this is i can't
remember the actor's name but he's the
same guy
that played um the uncle or the granddad
or whoever in
martin like that guy yeah cause that
because i was like hey that's
the dude from martin and he was in
martin like a year or two after this
because i think martin came out in 1975.
so they were all kind of like
and he so he comes on like it makes an
announcement at the beginning
um that pretty much everybody in this
movie is
uh you know volunteers uh and that you
know the lutherans like paid for the
[ __ ] and they wanted to talk about like
some aspects of
it's kind of like talking they're using
the amusement park which is a real
amusement park
um as sort of like a metaphor for life
and like all of the [ __ ] that life
throws at you and then it's kind of like
filtering that through the lens of once
you get old
you know you're not allowed to do [ __ ]
anymore like you said there's that one
scene like we're in the bumper cars
um but they're acting like it's really
like it's real traffic
so there's like this old lady driving
and then like her old husband is like in
the bumper car with her
and then some young douche in front of
them like makes an illegal turn and she
hits him
but but then the cop comes and then he
acts like it's her fault because she's
an old bat
who doesn't know how [ __ ] works and then
you know so that and then like the main
guy comes over he's like no i saw it
like the douche in the front like you
know did something illegal it wasn't her
fault
but then he's like aren't you supposed
to wear glasses you didn't see [ __ ] you
know you said grandpa or whatever
so it's just kind of like showing the
abuse that they go through all the time
yeah now some of this shit's situational
yeah it was it was a lot of the stuff
was
of the 70s and from that era
like yeah old people wrecked cars lot
back then
but 70s cars [ __ ] sucked the brakes
sucked yeah the steering sucked the
suspension was all over the place they
were [ __ ] huge
a young person of today would have a
hard time driving those old cars you
felt very insecure and unstable
like you were driving a [ __ ] boat
yeah
so and and they couldn't stop they
didn't have [ __ ] you know power
brakes
so yeah no power steering no power well
no they had power steering did they i
don't know
mostly they were luxury cars it was kind
of like but by today's standards they
would all be considered luxury cars it
would feel like you were driving around
inside your living room
like you're you're in your living room
and you're driving your living room
around the [ __ ] [ __ ]
their seats went out how big they were
you literally could have sex in those
cars
like easily well yeah you didn't have to
like cramp up or like you know
and they didn't break the gear shift or
anything yeah not like i've been there
but yeah
and we did have sex in those cars take
that [ __ ] down to the
hell yeah take take that [ __ ] down to
the [ __ ] drive-in park in the back
you'd have that [ __ ] car just
bouncing you look and seen the other
cars and go oh man
jason's in there getting it
you weren't even in each other's way
yeah everybody and his girlfriend
was back then yeah you're biting his
girlfriend being a front seat i mean you
could fit like four or five people in
the back seat like comfortably
it was it was [ __ ] sex fest
[ __ ] 86 man [ __ ] yeah listen to
87.
i laughed because you know on mystery
science theater they do a lot of uh
those old movies and a lot of these big
[ __ ] giant cars like from the 50s and
stuff
and they'll always make jokes about like
[ __ ] making boat noises when they're
turning they're like look they're all
standing up in that car
because like the car is so [ __ ]
awesome
so a lot of the problems they were
showing don't really exist anymore
uh uh they do but not
not to the extent like yeah you get you
have people in their 80s and 70s some of
them [ __ ] driving these
cars around quite competently they're a
lot smaller better handling
you know what i mean and as long as
they're not doing anything crazy an old
person can drive here
i mean and the thing about it too is
that you know and i'm not saying that
like old people don't get [ __ ] on
because they do
yeah but i'm just you know i'm saying
that some of the stuff like you said is
situational because there was one thing
in there
where it was kind of had to do with the
bumper car situation as well
where they were talking about well you
shouldn't you know we're gonna take your
license away and i know like a lot of
people that you know old people are like
freaking out because they lose their
independence and stuff
but i will submit that if you're [ __ ]
blind yeah you shouldn't be driving
should not be driving because there are
actually other people on the road other
than you
um so you know take the bus or get a
ride or
get uber it's much easier nowadays than
it was like that there's been several
instances where
an old person has panicked and instead
of slamming on the brakes they slam
on the damn accelerator and go right
through a [ __ ] crowd of people and
kill a bunch of people
well and well yeah and you know what the
convenience store behind my
grandmother's house
uh more than once i think it was two or
three times an
older person did exactly what you said
and drove through the front of the store
thankfully nobody was hurt yeah uh
because they stopped but
you know it did happen like more than
once at that one convenience they gotta
they gotta you know when you get to a
certain age they need to give these
people [ __ ] driving tests
to make sure that they can
neurologically handle it yeah and that's
not being
mean or we're not being like you know
you don't let a child drive
right we're not cracking down on you
know you don't let blind people drive
we're not just [ __ ] on them because
they're blind it's like you know
obviously they can't see the drives you
know you shouldn't be driving well soon
they're gonna have themselves driving
cars it won't matter
yeah i'm i can't wait for them to get in
the gun and go to sleep
i hate it well once you get to a certain
age you don't care about it anymore i
[ __ ] grew up driving
i could drive well i drive so well that
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] i can
[ __ ] sleep and drive the same time
please it's not even fun you know it's
not even fun like it was i got to ride a
motorcycle to have fun
so i wouldn't mind just you know getting
in the back of the van
laying down watching videos drink on the
way to the club
and on the way back from now on you
don't have to worry about like being
tired or you're too [ __ ] up to drive
or anything like that you can take a
long trip you're just sleeping in the
back of the van
watching you know i don't want it to be
a car i wanted to be like a van you
could walk around in well yeah because
then you could have like a room and a
television
[ __ ] go to sleep because you want a
sex den back yeah whatever yeah
and you'd be like watching porn man
and you know freaking riding the rump
[ __ ]
we'll be there in about eight hours i'm
gonna be there in about eight hours
have a popcorn machine yeah there a
little mini fridge watching movies
like i said i was i know some people are
like all like freaking out about
self-driving cars like bring them on man
as long as they work as long as they
work good yeah i mean but it can't be
that much worse than actual humans
driving because have you seen humans
drive they're really depends on who it
is they're really not that good at it in
general
but yeah so and there was another thing
in the movie too where
because so like i said what the conceit
of this movie is and why it kind of gave
me a little bit of a weird like black
mirrored surrealist kind of vibe
is that this uh you know the the the guy
from martin
is uh yeah i think louis said what his
name was but i can't remember what it
was what the actor's name was
but he's like dressed kind of like
colonel sanders or whatever looks like
this white suit on
and he goes into this totally white room
with nothing in there but a bunch of
other white chairs
and another version of him that looks
all
beat up and like [ __ ] up and bloody
and everything is sitting there
and he's trying to talk to the guy and
he's just like dad i want to talk i
don't want to do this and he's just like
well don't you want to go outside he's
like there's nothing out there worth
doing or anything and he's like well i'm
gonna go outside so it's like it's
almost like a purgatorial loop type of
thing
but so there's this other part too that
i was like might play differently
nowadays
but it should have played differently
then i don't know but so 1973 they're
trying to highlight
that you know this guy like the old guy
is
lonely because everybody's just like
like no one wants him around anymore
um so he's like sitting on a bench
eating some some crackers with peanut
butter like you do
and um he has there's these kids over
there like jumping rope or whatever
and he's like you know beckoning them
over
at which point i was just like stranger
danger but you know what i mean they
were trying to show that he's like he
was just trying to be like a kindly old
man
so the kids finally come over there and
then like a dude
probably rightfully so which is like hey
what are you some kind of
prevert or degenerate or whatever i
think he said degenerate
and i was like well yeah that's what you
would think it's like i don't want some
old grandpa at a bench going hey come
here children it's like yeah that's
that's that doesn't end well
um you know so so again i don't think
that's so much people picking on old
people that's just
because we have the experience now of
knowing that that's not a good situation
like some random old man like sitting on
a bench want your kids to come over
there and hang out with them
uh that's that's not gonna and the way
you think it is there we go
we're talking about um how bad the
florida drivers are because the
demographics you know they're talking
about
young people and old people it's more
than that man we'd be on this like an
i-4 and would have this [ __ ] car
tear ass past you and going through like
this i'm and i'm
and and growing up in brazil i'm like
that's a brazilian
we've got a huge brazilian population
here and in the way brazilians
just grow up driving you talk about
[ __ ]
ass holes the capital hole
well they don't think that the laws
apply to them yeah they don't give a
[ __ ] about any of those
and everything in brazil is a race a
traffic jam
is a challenge to race damn we're going
to figure out how to get around this
get around that [ __ ] and then we'll run
right into it try to get around a
traffic jam somehow and that traffic jam
would be 10 miles deep and they're
trying to
get around it that would explain some of
the only in brazil
i mean brazilian thinking i4
is a horrifying i mean if i have to go
anywhere that i have to we don't have to
get on i-4 you can go around it but a
lot of times it takes longer
i will just try to avoid it at all costs
because i really really hate
going i [ __ ] hate that road brazilian
the brazilian standard driving mode is
40 miles above speed limit whatever the
speed limit is they're going 40 miles
above
speed limit here is about 70 but you
know so they're gonna be going
120.
yeah remember that yeah we've had them
just pass i'll be going 80
and they'll just pass you yeah and then
they'll try to [ __ ] weave into all
these damn cars
and it's and it's piling up in a traffic
jam and there's not even an on
where the [ __ ] [ __ ] there's not
even an off ramp what are you gonna go
drive in the [ __ ] i gotta get in
front of all i gotta get in front of all
these people jesus christ
that's terrifying yeah terrifying yeah
brazil's like that 24 7.
we have to drive on it tonight too yeah
because we're going to memento yeah
sleazy bees ask me jenny do you still
see that cat on the walking trail i do i
have it i didn't see him today
i saw him last time i saw him was
thursday and actually the last time i
saw him
he was actually looking real good like
it looks like because remember i said he
seemed kind of skinny
and he had all those mats in his hair
and i said somebody had cut the mats out
and i'd kind of got a grooming glove and
i'd groomed him but it looks like
somebody had been kind of grooming him
so it looks like some of the hair grew
back
and um he actually seems like he's
gained some a little bit of weight
like now you pet him and you can't
really feel the ribs anymore because you
to be able to feel the ribs
so when i saw him on thursday like he
came over because i hadn't seen him in a
while because i'd been on vacation
and he came running up like me me me and
i was like well hey dude and he was like
i was like man you're looking good
and he just like sat there and let me
pet him and [ __ ] like that but yeah he
was looking really good but i haven't
seen him
since thursday but he's around i guess
like nobody said cause there's other
people on the path too that's em
and nobody told me that you know that
anything bad had happened so i'm
assuming that they had seen him as well
and there was there was a bowl of food
there this morning it's just he wasn't
out
but yeah so this so this movie it's not
it's only 53 minutes um so it's not like
it's still a movie and i would even sort
of call it a horror movie
yeah because it's like some kind of
black mirror yeah it's like this kind of
surreal
like nightmarish kind of but it also has
that weird psa thing
too because they are i mean i'm very
obviously trying to make a point
so it's just kind of like all these
different like situations
going like hey doesn't it suck that you
know old people don't have enough money
to live on and hey doesn't it suck that
you know nobody cares about [ __ ]
about old people or nobody wants to hang
out with them or
you know or they can't do this that the
other thing so it's kind of all
structured like that but because it's
george romero it still kind of comes off
like a horror movie even though i'm not
sure if that's what he intended
but i guess what ed what ended up
happening was that
when he showed the movie to the
lutherans which cracked me up because it
made me think of
like ed wood making [ __ ] plan 9 from
outer space like with the money from the
baptists
and him being like this baptists are
stupid stupid stupid
did it reminded me that so i wondered if
like george romero was like these
lutherans are stupid
so that's what i thought but so i guess
the lutheran saw it and we're like yeah
we can't show this
because like why'd you make it like a
horror movie i'm like why'd you hire
george romero because duh
um you know what i mean he made night of
the living dead for [ __ ] sake what'd
you think he was gonna do
but uh so they were like yeah we can't
show this and so
i guess they just stashed it away
somewhere he stashed it away somewhere
and nobody knew like i guess everybody
just thought it got
lost or destroyed or whatever and so
then i guess um
a year or two ago somebody found it
and uh realized what it was and then
they had like you know the george romero
foundation which i guess they have that
now and i love the logo it's like his
his glasses you know he has those really
iconic like big thick
[ __ ] glasses that he always wore with
like blood splattered on him that's the
[ __ ] logo which i loved it
but so they kind of uh paid to have the
movie restored
and then i don't know if they're gonna
release it on blu-ray or anything like
that but i just saw it turn up on
shutter and i'm like what the [ __ ]
is that i was like i take a look at that
so i didn't really know what to expect
i didn't really read the description all
i saw was lost george romero film from
1973 and i was like okay whatever so i
decided to check it out
so is so don't go into it thinking it's
like a narrative type movie
because it's not exactly but i don't
know it's real weird and if you're
really into george romero it's like a
really interesting
kind of time capsule of that yeah it's
not bad
it's like you said it's kind of a downer
though yeah it's a downer i mean because
it's like especially if you're getting
getting on in years like we are and just
like you know yeah that's all this [ __ ]
you gotta look forward to
like everyone you get old and then
it [ __ ] sucks and then you die
it's like something it's like something
out of twilight zone but it's kind of
like a mean
spirited toilet it doesn't have a happy
end and you're like then you die
well it's a and it's no it's worse than
that because like i said it's it's like
an endless loop
because he keeps coming back into that
plain white room with the other beat-up
version of himself
and the beat-up version of himself who's
been through all this [ __ ] is trying to
tell the clean version of himself hey
don't go out there but he's like no i'm
going anyway so like every single time
you go
i think what is supposed to symbolize is
that it was generations of old people
reaching old age over and over again
that's exactly what people are like that
that's exactly what it was
and eventually you're going to be there
and you keep trying to tell people like
when they're going to be
like you tell young people it's like you
know i've been through this and it's
like
yeah [ __ ] you you don't know what you're
talking about i'm different like no it's
that same group of people
always [ __ ] going through that [ __ ]
over and over again eventually you go in
there
yeah which that you know that is kind of
a horror movie
but thing is is that things have changed
a lot since the 70s
yeah old age has changed a lot yeah i
mean it's not
internet and social media have changed
the lives of old people
and everything's changing for the bad
new drugs and hormone
therapies and [ __ ] all kinds of stuff
changed the life okay for instance
i'm only a little bit younger than those
people they were calling old people but
you should look at them
yeah they were [ __ ] old well they're
all like toddling around on the walkers
and [ __ ] like that
the lives that they lived the diets that
they had
what their jobs were like the [ __ ]
the chemicals and [ __ ] they were exposed
to
[ __ ] the lack of lack of [ __ ]
anti-aging medicines and [ __ ] everything
is an anti-aging
medicine you just don't realize it
brushing your teeth is anti-aging well
they didn't really
know a lot about i mean even about like
health and fitness and diet and [ __ ]
like that they didn't really know
what we know now they were kind of
semi-sedentary sitting around
working themselves to death in offices
or working themselves in death standing
still in a damn factory very kind of
almost third world like something you
see out of china
and they lived very fast hard and they
died kind of young
or when and then when they didn't die
young they looked a lot older than they
were when they died
you know i noticed like even younger
people back then looked older
yeah than they do nowadays we're talking
about people that were in in dying mode
in when i was a little boy when i was
three this is
1973 i was only three or four years yeah
like our grandparents
grandparents not even my parents not
even parent's age they didn't live
that long and the quality of their life
wasn't that good they were considered to
be
the greatest generation they got a lot
of [ __ ] done but at the at their own
expense
yeah a lot of them didn't live outside
their teens they were killed in the damn
world war yeah that's true
[ __ ] yeah a lot of them especially
the european ones europe took [ __ ]
heavy hits
i mean freaking by the end of world war
ii germany looked like the surface of
the moon
a lot of people don't realize that i
mean it was literally bombed to [ __ ]
yep just bomb craters everywhere
little kids and [ __ ] dead people yeah
yeah scott says
uh oh wait no i saw scott said do you
get tired of explaining that the world
existed before 1990
yeah man there are people that just
there are people that are old enough
walking around have no idea what a world
was like before internet
it's it's it's astounding well and the
people and those people
are now adults and have kids of their
own which is crazy
and they're having jobs and they're
producing stuff you're like
i mean it's not their fault they can't
you know they can't help when they were
born
right it's just they don't realize how
much of a change they'll go back and
critique something that was happening in
the 80s or the 90s
and they don't realize how different it
actually was
what life was like shopping was totally
different back then
access to music and media totally
different everything was physical medium
well yeah records and albums and cds
well it was i was it's funny because i
was thinking about this
because i was talking about uh on one of
my movie reviews that i recorded earlier
and i was talking about uh the stephen
king book dance macabre
which is you know his nonfiction book
where he talks about horror i said when
he wrote that in the early 1980s and he
was talking about horror like movies and
stuff like that from 1950 to 1980
and i said you have to remember that
when he wrote that book you couldn't go
back and watch those movies
yeah he was writing about them from his
memory of them
and sometimes he got it wrong uh you
know because you
you couldn't check yeah pretty much you
know there was no internet you couldn't
just go back and watch it anytime you
wanted to
he just had to go by his memory of it
and some of the movies he saw when he
was a kid
and um you know and he didn't get some
of the details right
flow of information was totally
different you had no way of checking
what somebody else was doing if they
were working on the same problem you're
working on like something maybe having
to do guns or
engines or motor you couldn't check his
work over there you couldn't see it
and you couldn't you didn't know who who
else in the world was working on the
same problem you were working on
now a group of guys can go on the
internet and through youtube and trade
damn youtube videos about how to [ __ ]
fix something that didn't happen back in
the day
well yeah it's like easy you don't even
think about it think about it it's like
they could be on the other side of the
planet and you're just like hey i'm
working the same [ __ ] as you let's and
you can like talk to them in real time
and they'll be crazy
you can go back and see somebody working
on that same problem
12 years ago and you go okay yeah and
see how he did it
you that was that was that that's a huge
boost
to people's abilities i could go back i
can go on the internet
and find out medical information and
medical inf
knowledge back in the day dudes just had
to guess or go to a doctor
now you could you can access the same
info that the doctor has
if you know how to search for it just
just amazing
amazing abilities of amazing flow of
information
undreamed of i would have never imagined
it
well it's weird because i mean it
doesn't seem that weird to me i guess
because we were around
when it came when it happened so to us
it was like an incremental
yeah but i at the time it was a comment
in the 90s i didn't realize
what the ultimate impact would be yeah i
don't think anybody did yeah
i don't think anything the first thing
that really struck me in the 90s is that
i could order clothes online
and that blew my [ __ ] mind back in
the late 90s i was buying
i was in mississippi on the gulf coast
buying goth clothes online with a credit
with a credit card it was actually an
atm card with a credit card
atm card when that was like damn's like
something out of god damn
the running man or [ __ ] arnold
schwarzenegger science
science fiction movie and i was like you
don't have to physically be in a
location to shop
and then i looked at the mall and i said
what's that why that's not going to
exist i was thinking that in the 90s
those are going to go obsolete
everybody's just going to do this
eventually but you were like
an elite few people
online shopping wow i mean they've
always had
they've always had like mail-order stuff
yeah ever since like you know the late
19th century i think online but yeah
you know i knew that that was going to
have a serious impact it eventually did
it was the death of the shopping mall do
you remember that like i remember when
there were no such things as atm cards
yes there were credit cards for a long
time before they actually figured out
hey let's do a debit card
yeah because i remember when debit cards
came out because i didn't have one for
i had an atm i had an atm card i think
it was in 1988.
i can't remember when i got we just
called them bank cards i think i didn't
get one until the 90s
it was a bank card it wasn't an atm card
you could use the card to access an atm
machine
and get cash yeah eventually
you didn't have to get the cash you
could swipe the card yeah
register and that's really the beginning
of the bank card and i think that was
what 90 something
i feel like it was probably the 90s 96
maybe 97 it kind of happened slowly
but i just i just remember i remember
people having credit cards but i don't
remember atm cards until like the 90s
yeah i was doing that [ __ ] and i was
going what's cash for you know
what you know it slowly cat now i
realize i haven't really
touched cash to speak of in over 10
years not really the only
the only thing i need cash for is like
to pay the parking gap when we go
down when we go downtown you don't even
need that he's got a [ __ ] thing you
can swipe it
well he didn't used to he didn't used to
be so i always have cause i don't ever
know where we're gonna end up parking
and some of them have that and some of
them don't
so i usually carry like five or ten
bucks in cash just in case uh you know
that i get out of the atm just in case
like we have to park somewhere that's
cash only
but yeah um yeah fortunate announcement
i got my first atm card in 1990.
yeah i'm just talking about standing in
line to buy tickets for van halen
i remember yeah i remember going like
real i was buying tickets for uh i guess
it was depeche mode or something like
that and i had to like wait a really
long time i got there at like three in
the morning and waited in front of the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and then these people don't even
remember a lot of these kids have no
idea that there was such a thing called
long-distance telephone charges remember
that [ __ ]
is that a long distance call i can't
call you i can't cause
it's long distance yeah then you get the
phone bill and your dad would be like
who are you calling
it's like 200 yeah they charge you an
arm and a leg
and then sometime in the 90s somebody
called me over my phone and they were on
a laptop
not a laptop they were on a a pc yeah
they had a program to circumvent it and
it would call your phone
yeah i feel like i feel like um they had
a lot of those kind of uh
late night tv commercials and they were
always trying to get something to kind
of work around the long distance charges
like a thing you could plug into your
wall and show you yeah
it was weird it didn't last long they
went obsolete real
fast but you know the guys on the
cutting edge could just call you over
their
pc and they probably were like i'm like
a hacker
yeah yeah yeah man
yeah little did they know it looks so
[ __ ] rude by today's yeah but it is
standard but i mean because everything
happened so quickly
yeah so long distance charges yeah so
like you said i was like
but i found this movie really
interesting because
you could see i mean some of the stuff
hasn't really changed but you can really
see how
aging uh is even different yeah
nowadays than it was back in the 1970s
yeah
um you know so some of the stuff that
they bring up in there is obviously
still relevant but
you know even i think on old people
sometimes yeah they're talking about our
grandparents generation
that's what yeah that's who they're
showing in this and
our grandparents generation could have
never imagined to say
a woman like dolly parton in her mid-70s
it looks great
that looks pretty much the same when i
was a kid
big old rock hard boobs
tacky kind of sexy same thing with cher
you know what i mean but she owns the
tackiness
she tells you that it's tacky yeah
that's well she loves that kind of [ __ ]
that's like her whole aesthetic
yeah and she seems like a lovely person
yeah my grandparents generation
actually that wasn't even grandparents
generation because in 73 my grandparents
weren't that old they'd been
great-grandparents probably almost
maybe was i was born in 72 and my
parents
were only 18 right in 1972.
so yeah that generation grandpa
great-grandparents generation
because they were in their 80s in the 73
in 73 these people that they're showing
are supposed to be in their 80s i think
and then in the 70s
getting ready to die my grandparents
weren't that old in the 70s they were
younger than that they think they would
have been around their 60s probably
yeah i'm sure it was in the 70s i think
my grandparents were only in their 50s
50s or 60s right yeah so they didn't
seem that they were even older than that
so really that generation if they'd see
somebody like dolly parton that would
have been like an alien from another
planet they just didn't have people that
looked like that
they didn't have people that healthy at
that age yeah i mean once you got into
like your mid 50s you were
kind of falling apart yeah you were done
you looked like the the portrait of the
picture of dorian gray like
the picture not the actual guy very few
people aged well
yeah sleazy b says i remember in the 80s
just calling the next town over was long
distance
yeah it was you could only call locally
only in your neighborhood
pretty much yeah only like in your town
yeah next town over that was yeah if i
because i grew up in daytona
if you called deltona which is like 20
miles away
that was long distance yep all right so
you ready to wrap it up and wrap it up
all right i mean we've been going more
than half an hour yeah i gotta check the
mail
oh yeah that's right uh so yeah so it's
monday right yeah yeah
okay so tomorrow we'll probably do a
food show tomorrow like an on the menu
because
we're going out tonight yeah we're gonna
be wore out and we're gonna be wore out
and we're not gonna have a chance to
watch another movie
so we'll probably talk about food
tomorrow i don't know what i don't know
i'll come up with something
we'll come up with something but yeah we
will be back uh tomorrow probably kind
of tired but we'll try to we'll try to
power through it we'll be back tomorrow
at
three o'clock eastern standard time as
always and uh thanks everybody for
dropping by have a good rest of your
monday
and we'll see you guys tomorrow